THE IABULHANKS S MUCH
PETEREOOK FORRD TO NEW
INRMATN AS YOUET I
JOS RIG NOW IS FOX NE
CORIBUR FOUR-STAR RIREDGENERAL .
HOUSE AND I IT IS KL?
>> GOO EVENG BRIAN, THISS
GREAT NS NOTNLY R THE U.S.
BUT R THE ENRE WORLD.
MY HATS OFF TOHE GAT MEN AND
MEN IN UNIFO AS LL AS THE
INTELLIGENCEGENC THAT WE
ABLE T BRI INHE JUSCE.
HE H BEENROBLEM FOR USLL
E WA BACK TO THE U.S.
MBIN.
IS IS A MOR VTORY FORHE
WAR ANERROSM.
Bri: NO DOUBT ABO IT
WAA RIGHT-HD MAN A DEEP
THINR ANGSIDE USAMA
BIN LADEN F YEA.
WASN AND ARRESD AER THE
HE'S BEEN AT IT. HOWONG
WE A HRING THE FAC THAT HE
WAS LINGN RIDENTIALREA
KAB OUT IN THE OPEN ATHEY'VE B,
AT IS ATT SAY AUT THE
MFORT HEELT  AHANIAN'S
CAPITAL TO ME Y UNDERSTANTHROLEA
NEW GOVERENT?
WL TS IS A POI OF
RLLY COULDN'T B TREOLY
VING AROUND WIOUT SE
KNOWDGE  THAT THEALIB
THE UNANSWERE QUEION AND
PRABLY BEST NOT  THI ABOUT
A PUBLICLY ITO BET ANY
INSIDE INFORTIONROM THETABAN?
IS IS THE UNKNN PT RHT
PUBLIC DOES NOTNOW.THE
THATS THEROBL WITH THIS
SUCCESSF IT REQRES SOME SAFE
HAVENS, SOMAREAF SUPPORFROM SE Y
D TH'S ALWAY CLLENGE
THAT WE HAVE GLOBAY
>> Brian: GENERALVERHE
SE A WORK IN TS CASE HOW
MUCH BETTER ULD  IF WE D
WOULD BE RIGHNEXT DOO
WITH BIN LADENN CHGE WHEN WE
KILL HIM AND WITH WAHI IN
CHARGE WHEWEILLE HIM?
>> I THINK TT BILADEN WTHE BGERN
TTHE DAY TODAY OPERATO.
RKIN THE LOGISTICSHEYACH
HAD ECIFIC ROLES.
SO HIM LEAVI THE SCENEOTHS
E DIGNATED LEADER A REAY
LLOW OF BIN LEN AS WL AS
THE KEY ORATO OVE DECADESS
A MAJ HITOR AL QAEDA>> Brian GEY
SOOR JNING US TONIG WE
PRECTED.